[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what up internet I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's December 15th in
the year 2022 and the big Reuben report
holiday party is tonight so we've got to
do a tight show so that these fine
people can go home and put on their
Tuxedos and whatever else they're going
to do there's going to be a lot of
tequila this evening we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV
if you have not subscribed jump over to
rumble.com reubenreport and
reubenreport.com locals where you can
live chat with us and get extra bonus
video streams and I posted some pictures
of the kids this morning and all that
good stuff if you did not know what that
cold open was so that video which was I
have to admit it was doctored
misinformation specialist you know uh
that was uh yesterday Nancy Pelosi was
unveiling her portrait uh in the capital
uh but the the meme makers of the
internet I believe it was the people
over at post-millennial they put the
picture of non-binary gender fluid Biden
nuclear waste official and also bag
Thief criminal Sam Brinton if you've
missed this story it's just so nuts so
there's this guy or girl or whatever he
is he wears puppy outfits he's having a
good time lipstick and dresses the whole
thing he's also he's also a nuclear
waste Specialist or something and uh he
apparently twice
two times so you know it's not a mistake
went on a flight went down to baggage
claim and took other people's bags
did not even check a bag just went down
in stole bags so he I think has been let
go as of yesterday so I thought that was
just a little fun way to start the show
and uh as for what we're doing today uh
it's going to be a pickup on a lot of
things that uh we've been talking about
in general but sort of specifically
yesterday uh fauci this Anthony fauci
guy who is just being exposed left and
right as as a fraud and a liar and on
the Dole and on the take and all of that
stuff and and really as someone who has
taken every position on covid all along
the way uh he is now firing back at
Governor Ron DeSantis here in Florida we
talked about yesterday Governor DeSantis
has now commissioned this panel of
people including a couple couple former
guests of this show Dr Jay bhattacharya
from Stanford Brett Weinstein couple
other people to look into vaccine
injuries to look into how the CDC and
fauci himself may have pushed bunk
science on on us and and what that did
to the Civil Rights rights of Floridians
so that's actually very exciting but
it's not just the the corruption and the
lies of covid we're kind of seeing it
everywhere right now which of course is
connected to what Elon Musk is doing
with Twitter where we're getting more
information so as I always say it's like
if you've managed to stay roughly sane
over the last couple years I give you a
lot of credit I would say I'm just
roughly saying like just roughly saying
that's all you had to do because we were
inundated with such misinformation the
truth was so consistently hidden from us
and they pushed nonsensical policies
that they knew did not work we can only
guess why they did it uh well I think we
can speculate and probably figure out
some pretty good reasons these people
like money and power that's basically it
uh and we're pushing back and more and
more people are seeing what's what and
we have to just keep putting the
pressure on the private institutions the
public institutions and much more so
that's what we're going to be doing
today before we get to it let me talk to
you guys about story worth you know this
holiday season I want to give a gift to
my loved ones that makes them feel
special and unique just like the
relationship we share that's why I'm
giving everyone I care about story worth
story worth is an online service that
helps you and your loved ones preserve
precious memories and stories for years
to come it's a thoughtful and meaningful
gift that connects you to those who
matter most every week with story worth
emails every week story worth emails
your relative or friend a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from their vast pool of possible
options each unique prompt asks
questions you've never thought to ask
like what's the bravest thing you've
ever done in your life or if you could
see into the future what would you want
to find out
after one year story worth Will compile
all your loved ones stories including
photos into a beautiful Keepsake book
that you'll be able to share and
re-visit for generations to come I'm
going to give my keepsake book to my two
baby boys when they are older and Justin
spit up all over me twice today reading
the weekly stories helps connect you
with loved ones no matter how near or
far apart you are with story worth I'm
giving those I love most a thoughtful
personal gift from the heart and
preserving their memories and stories
for years to come go to storyworth.com
Reuben and save ten dollars on your
first purchase that's storyworth.com
Reuben to save ten dollars on your first
purchase and now back to me I will tell
you guys I so I take the kids in the
morning and Justin I had him this
morning we do the full bottle he's at
six ounces right now and he's sucking
this thing down I was like he is kind of
eating this thing fast the kid must be
starving and then I'm trying to burp him
he spit up I mean all over my face all
over my shirt then I was like oh he's
spitting up all of me I kind of turn him
around and he spits up all over my show
words anyway I didn't use hairspray
today it's just spit up
it works it works there's a viscosity to
it and a hole that's very impressive all
right let's talk about this Anthony
fauci fraud Anthony crunchy uh he went
on CNN yesterday to talk about what Ron
DeSantis is doing right here in Florida
and he's clearly nervous and just watch
if you want to see the beautiful
Perfection of the mainstream Media Watch
as the interviewer asks him an extremely
loaded question and clearly is on his
side in this whole thing so politicized
as as covet 19. I mean you've found
yourself we've talked about this many
times at the center of some of that
angry debate Elon Musk just came at you
and attacked you but the latest now Dr
fauci is Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
he's now asking the Florida Supreme
Court to Greenlight an investigation
into in the way he put it is any uh any
and all wrong doing in Florida with
respect to covid-19 vaccines
what's your reaction to that
I don't have a clue Kate what he's
asking for I mean we have a vaccine that
unequivocally is highly effective and
safe and has saved literally millions of
lives that's a very difficult situation
you're absolutely correct it has been
politicized and it has been politicized
in a way that has actually caused lives
because if people don't get vaccinated
which unequivocally is life-saving
because of political ideology
everything he said there is a lie it
never stops with the guy the balls on
this bureaucratic buffoon are large he
has large balls I'll give him that a
couple things there first off the
vaccines are not highly effective fact
check me fact Checkers Joe Biden last
June if you get the vaccine you will not
get nor transmit covid that is what
wolensky at the CDC told us that is what
fauci told us that is what virtually
every government official told us before
this if you were vaccinated against
something before the covid vaccine you
did not get the thing that's what we all
thought vaccine meant Oh you get a bat
you're vax from polio you ain't gonna
get polio polio polio vaccine polio that
way polio doesn't go this way it doesn't
get in the system but they've literally
literally changed the definition of
vaccine because the covid vaccines do
not work as every previous vaccine so
that's one thing then he says that it
saved millions of lives there's just no
evidence of this there is no long-term
evidence of this there may be some
evidence that people of a certain age
with some other diseases got some
temporary protection from covid Perhaps
Perhaps but there is no evidence that it
has saved millions and millions of lives
I don't think honestly at this point
that there's any evidence had we done
nothing and I really mean that
absolutely nothing we would have known
that there's this there's this kind of
flute like thing going around the world
and everyone's just going to kind of get
it and just remember everybody take care
of yourself don't don't forget to drink
a little water get a little sunshine
exercise every now and again maybe get
off your ass uh I think things probably
would have been better well I think
things for sure would have been better
at a sort of psychological level after
the the insanity and the gaslighting of
the last two and a half years uh and
also this idea that we're the ones that
politicize this thing we politicized it
by pushing back on the nonsense that's
what he's saying these people politicize
it meaning the Republicans or
conservatives whatever it's like wait a
minute wait a minute
first off in the world we live in now
everything is political but if you shut
people out of their jobs if you don't
let kids go to school if somehow
teachers union seem like they're in
cahoots with the uh with the science uh
the scientists and all of the the CDC
and the NIH and everything else you guys
made it political we're just calling out
your BS that's all it is so every single
thing that he says is like oh and then
the big one uh that they're that they're
safe and effective okay I already dealt
with the effective part right they're
just not effective in any way that we
used to think effective men safe well I
was at the panel the DeSantis panel two
days ago where he was assembling this
group of scientists and doctors uh to
deal with and look into some of these
vaccine injuries and much more one of
the doctors that he had there was ER Dr
Joseph Freeman there is he has done many
many studies on this I don't as far as I
can tell you could correct me if I'm
wrong if you're watching this on the
computer machine uh nobody is
questioning his credentials really
related to any of this and when fauci
says safe what Dr Freeman talked about
was how Pfizer and moderna know this
that when they were putting these
vaccines out that there was a one in 800
chance that there was going to be a
highly adverse reaction and what he's
talking about is heart disease serious
stuff not just like you're going to be
you know you're gonna have aches and
pains for a day or two like you might
have if you got the flu vaccine
something like that one in 800. now that
you may say well 1800 doesn't sound that
doesn't sound that bad well when it
comes to other vaccines like the polio
vaccine and things of that nature it's
one in a million that is a massive
extraordinary difference one in 800 and
we're forcing the vaccine on all these
people that don't need it on top of all
the myocarditis stuff and all that uh
but one in 800 is very very different
than one in a million but that's what
these people do but let's continue
because I don't want to focus too much
on Factory I don't like them very much
why am I talking about them so much
let's move on to some other people that
aren't very good uh you guys all know
this story about uh FTC which was the
crypto exchange run by this absolute
charlatan by the name of Sam bankman
freed and FTX collapsed it basically was
in a complete Ponzi scheme where they
were taking money from people putting it
in essence into like this shell company
that did nothing and they were buying
all sorts of properties and his parents
became rich and they've moved all sorts
of money nobody's where it knows where
any of the money is he got all kinds of
people involved in this thing
celebrities athletes Tom Brady got
screwed on this thing a whole bunch more
well anyway he was supposed to testify
in front of Congress yesterday but
magically he got arrested the day before
so was unable to do so here is video of
sdny
attorney Damian Williams detailing the
charges against Sam bankman freed now
let me say a little bit more about what
we allege in the indictment
first we charge up in 2019 until earlier
this year Bateman freed and his
co-conspirator stole billions of dollars
from FTX customers
he used that money for his personal
benefit including to make personal
Investments and to cover expenses and
debts of his hedge fund Alameda research
secondly and relatedly we charge that
bankman free lie to alameda's lenders
about the source of the money that he
was using to pay those debts
third we charged that earlier this year
in the midst of the crypto crisis
bankman freed lied to investors in FTX
about the fact that he had sent billions
of dollars in FTX customer money to
Alameda
and fourth we charge a bankman freed
violated Federal campaign Finance laws
by causing tens of millions of dollars
in a legal campaign contributions to be
made to candidates and committees
associated with both Democrats and
Republicans
these contributions were disguised to
look like they were coming from wealthy
co-conspirators when in fact the
contributions were funded by Alameda
research with stolen customer money
and all of this dirty money was used in
service of bankman Freed's desire to buy
bipartisan influence and impact the
direction of public policy
okay so this is pretty powerful stuff
with this guy this story you may be
watching this story and going well wait
a minute there's always fraud on Wall
Street and crypto sounds kind of shady
and people involved in finances do all
sorts of weird stuff and we've heard
about Madoff and Ponzi schemes and all
the rest of it but what really is
interesting about this is how connected
this guy was to the political Elite and
that this story did not break shocker
this story did not break till the day
after the midterm elections when all the
checks were cashed all the analysts and
the advisors were paid and everybody got
their little piece the day after
suddenly oh my it does turn out that
this guy who didn't really have a
product who's been put on every TV show
and we're told he's Jesus too uh he's
actually a massive Charlotte and so you
know you could say he's already stole
billions he used it for personal use he
lied to lenders he lied to investors the
big one is the campaign Finance stuff so
we've got a little bit more from Fox
News on that two of the biggest
Democrats beneficiaries of disgraced FTX
founder Sam bankman Freed's campaign
donations reportedly won't say whether
they plan to return the donations in
total bankman freed reportedly spent
upward of 40 million on campaigned Ocean
campaign donations in the 2022 midterm
cycle with the vast majority going to
Democrats the disgraced crypto
billionaire was arrested in the Bahamas
on Monday evening just as Federal
prosecutors in New York filed charges
against him the U.S Securities and
Exchange Commission and the commodity
Futures Trading commission also filed
charges against bankman freed on Tuesday
in total bankman freed face charge faces
charges of conspiracy to commit wire
fraud on customers committing wire fraud
on customers conspiracy to commit wire
fraud on lenders committing wire fraud
on lenders conspiracy to commit
Commodities fraud conspiracy to commit
Securities fraud conspiracy to commit
money laundering and conspiracy to
defraud the U.S and violate campaign
Finance laws and conspiracy to have the
worst haircut
I've ever seen uh look this is a big
story because he was stealing money not
only using it for all his own selfish
purposes okay fine that's that's like
corrupt guy 101 but he was buying
influence with politicians and as the uh
attorney in New York said he was doing
it on both sides however it was wildly
wildly pro-democrat and by the way many
many politicians this is something
Donald Trump talked an awful lot about
in 2015 and 2016. an awful lot of rich
people buy influence on both sides like
you might give more to the guy you
really want in but you also want to
hedge your bets so Trump used to say
well I would give money to Democrats and
Republicans Hillary I used to give money
to you now you tell me I'm a Nazi
because they're hedging their bets you
might want one person to win a little
bit more generally they want Democrats
to win a little bit more because they're
more part of the machine and the
machine's been pretty good to super
wealthy people I know that's a little
counter-intuitive relative to taxes but
that's generally how it works
um but he was the second largest
Democrat donor he was in the Democrat
machine here he is with lovely lady
Maxine Waters I mean look at this guy
look what what a clown show who are
these people anyway yesterday the
hearing that that he was supposed to be
at but did not get to because he's now
been arrested what a wonderful
coincidence that was so he wasn't able
to testify under oath Maxine Waters is
on the committee that was leading this
thing and she who has defended him who
got money from him how much is Maxine
Waters worth Maxine Waters who is
representative in the LA suburb which is
one of the the poorest suburbs she
doesn't live there though she lives in
Hancock Park which is one of the richest
areas in all of La she's got to be worth
at least 20 million I'm going to throw
out 20 million she's been she's been in
Congress forever how much is it five no
fifty 10 million she's worth a cool 10
million I don't know how she did that on
a mere government salary anyway she was
part of the hearing yesterday and
basically she was trying to silence
other Representatives who wanted to ask
questions it's really rather remarkable
and just smug gross awful lady goat Rick
the closing statements from ranking
member McHenry and myself uh and I'd
like to thank you Mr John Ray III
chairwoman Waters presence here today
chairwoman Waters I've not had an
opportunity to testify or to question
the witness
I'd like to
um thank you for your presence
chairwoman Waters
parliamentary inquiry yes are all
members entitled to question Witnesses
you are and if you would like to miss
the boats on the floor for everybody
it's the chairwoman's prerogative to
call it one moment that's your decision
not mine
just one moment please you may go right
ahead and have five minutes thank you
thank you madam chair you're certainly
welcome sir you're certainly welcome sir
she's just awful good and had every
right to ask questions and have his boys
heard and everything else but you
very odd to me why would she would want
to shut this thing down real quick and
uh you know for those of you I haven't
done a Star Wars reference in a while
that was literally a scene from Star
Wars the prequels yeah I'm going to the
prequels remember in Phantom Menace when
there's the Trade Federation blockade of
Naboo and queen abidala takes it to the
Senate and they're up there and she's
pleading her case she's going you know
there the the the the separatists
they're blocking us you know what are we
going to do either attacking us all this
stuff we have no weapons and then
Chancellor of velorium standing there
just like Maxine Waters is and then this
guy comes in his ear and Whispers
something to him which is exactly what
that woman did to Maxine Waters the next
thing you know nothing happens these
people are terrible
I like them very much uh let's continue
because Sam bankman freed and again you
may say well all right it doesn't matter
so he gave money to politicians so he's
corrupt so all of this stuff always
happens so crypto is a you know a scam
like you might think all of that stuff
but why is it that this guy was so
beloved by the system that's the real
question why is it that this guy was on
every podcast
why was it that this guy was on every TV
show every media organization was
writing glowing reviews of this guy why
was that
here's a compilation of uh the giant
suck job that these people were doing on
him you've been now described as the JP
Morgan if you will of the crypto
business a lot of people have called you
um the savior of crypto the Patriot
saint of crypto the Michael Jordan of
crypto if you will Sam free same bank
been free to JP Morgan free SPF JPM do
you know SPF I think it's cool that the
guy has just initials uh SPF some on
Twitter calling him the hero right now
of the industry there's comparisons to
Warren Buffett
of 1907 bailing out the banks before the
Fed was even created Sam bankman free
just trying to play the role of JP
Morgan uh the original tape in the
morning one key figure we've talked
about has emerged to help stabilize the
ecosystem that is sambang been freed we
talk about him a lot Sam bankman free
free is he the Jake Gould of our era or
is he the JP Morgan Embark I think it's
yet to be determined yet to be
determined is he Vanderbilt he could be
G Harriman possibly there's the credit
mobile air Scandal see Carnegie the
aforementioned 29 year old gazillionaire
FDX founder and CEO Sam bankman freed I
love you Sam I'm just jealous
nothing nothing against you the CEO
though lives a relatively understated
life for a billionaire he drives a
Toyota Corolla to ftx's offices in the
Bahamas he lives with 10 roommates and a
golden doodle named gopher sometimes
sleeps under uh his desk on a beanbag
chair as well you know I'm not an
incredible investor I I don't have a lot
in the market I don't uh tried to do
some things with property I believe in
physical things that's my thing but I
don't think I would have given that guy
money does that guy oh he's sleeping
under his desk he has the body of a 70
year old man while he's 26 his haircut
looks like uh it was given to him by a
criminally insane person you know like
everything about the whole thing read as
so freaking weird to have any of these
people offered apologies have any of
these people had Maya culpas have any of
these people been like boy I really got
Bamboozled on that one but now I want to
connect this to something more broad
which is that certain people of a
certain political belief are loved by
the system this is the idea of factory
settings if you just kind of grow up in
America let's say over the last 40 years
the culture is so skewed to the left
towards the Democrats towards liberals
that the default position is oh that
must be good and then anytime anyone
wakes up out of that then your thought
of is the bad guy which is why to go to
what we were talking about earlier fauci
can do all of this bad [ __ ] get all of
this stuff wrong really just have no
regard for individual rights or a
constitution or anything like that but
it's only politicized in his view when
we push back because the default
position is always the position of the
left and if you want a great example of
that MRC TV put together a really nice
compilation you may know that the Daily
Show host Trevor Noah who has hosted the
show for I think the last seven years
since Jon Stewart stepped away and it
went from being sort of a cultural icon
whether you watched it or not whether
you like Jon Stewart or not whether you
thought it was good or not it was a it
was a sort of main stream
place where politics Was Heard and
talked about and it was thought as the
most sort of irreverent political comedy
on television uh basically Trevor Noah
takes over and the things become
completely irrelevant so they're finally
getting rid of him and it's fairly
obvious they would have gotten rid of
him years ago but because of the
identity politics game like clearly they
couldn't do that which is also why he
got the job in the first place because
there were plenty of other qualified
actually funny people that could have
got it anyway MRC TV did a little
compilation on this and a study on uh
how many guests he had on that were
political by nature and whether they
were left or right liberal or
conservative or much more here's a
little info for you during his seven
year tenure as host of comedy Central's
The Daily Show Trevor Noah brought a
reliably liberal bias to the program a
NewsBusters study has found MRC analysts
found that from when Noah began hosting
the show in September of 2015 through
his final show in December of 2022 Noah
had on 100 59 partisan guests including
109 Unique Individuals of these 159
guests 137 or
86.16 percent were Democrats or in some
way affiliated with the Democrat Party
now I want to be clear I mostly at this
point in my career have right-leaning
guests on obviously we try to get
Democrats on all the time I would love
to have AOC on I would love to have Joe
Biden on I'll have ilhan Omar and the
head of Hamas what's her name you know
all of them I'll do all that stuff they
don't generally want to talk but I'm not
hiding what my political bias are right
like Comedy Central is thought of as a I
suppose an a political network but
everything they gave you everything they
made feel normal was from a leftist
perspective no one's coming here like
I'm bamboozling you as to what I believe
I tell you what I believe every second
of every day anyway here's a little
compilation of Trevor Noah's left-wing
bias
does this ever get
cheering for you when you walk into
rooms there seems to be this feeling
where you walk around the country and
people go it's a little bit of like oh
but it's also like Yay gender change is
not a trend all right it's been around
for thousands of years but if it was why
does the church care about it so much
first of all transgender people can
reproduce and secondly again why do you
care right you don't even let your
people reproduce right nuns aren't
allowed to have sex right priests can't
get little boys pregnant that same
Supreme Court ruling that struck down
Roe v Wade it also opened the door to
Future rulings that could overturn other
rights right things like the right to
gay marriage uh interracial marriage and
contraception here's the amazing part
for South Africa to achieve that kind of
black white wealth Gap we had to
construct an entire apartheid States
denying blacks the right to vote or own
property but you you did it without even
trying
you know one of the things that I find
interesting about this guy actually
probably the only thing I find
interesting about this guy is that you
know I'm very aware when I've toured all
over the world especially when I was on
tour with Jordan Peterson if I was in
some someone else's country you might
say something about like the food or
this or that but I went out of my way
not to insult the country not even to
not insult the leaders I think maybe the
one little caveat on that was I did go
pretty hard after Trudeau when we were
in Canada but Canada and America I
almost consider one thing at this point
this guy he comes here moves to this
country to just rip our country apart
relentlessly and endlessly by the way
that line at the beginning where he said
to Hillary what's it like to go
everywhere be applauded I actually puked
in my mouth a little bit so I've been
spit up on twice today and I had to
swallow my own vomit that's where I'm at
today guys that's what's going on over
here anyway this constant fear-mongering
of they're gonna reverse interracial
marriage and they're coming after gay
marriage yes uh that's what they're
doing that's really what they're doing
it's just it's
incredible anyway
the Senate passed this Defense of
Marriage Act even though it's already
Supreme Court law there's a lot of
people saying that that it's actually
what they've now passed will be an
affront to religious liberty let's just
put that aside for a moment but just
listen to the hysteria yesterday at the
at the White House the elderly man
pretending to be President Joe Biden
talking about gays and what's happening
to gays in America
when a person can be married in the
morning and thrown out of a restaurant
for being gay in the afternoon this is
still wrong
first off nobody gets married in the
morning people get married you're going
to get married in the afternoon to the
evening usually very few weddings take
place in the morning so I just like to
you know technically I think he's making
a little bit of a mistake there
um there is no evidence we did a whole
bunch of Googling yesterday
um of gay people being kicked out of
restaurants okay we have the quality act
like from
1963 something like that
um nobody's being kicked out of
restaurants for these things it's so
nonsensical you're not going to believe
this guys most people when they open up
a restaurant or you open up a uh you
know a shoe shop you open up some sort
of store you're not trying to figure out
the sexuality of the people that are
coming to buy product you're really just
trying to move products make a little
profit get a little scratch in your
pocket have a nice weekend that's
usually what you're trying to do you're
not trying to open up a waffle house and
be like oh my God those lesbians got
married this morning no waffles for them
it's just nonsense but this is what they
do with absolutely everything now it's
one one thing just this like pandering
nonsense around the Gaze they're coming
for your marriage and they're coming for
interracial marriage and all that but
what the Democrats really love more than
anything right now it's so sick and
twisted but they freaking love it is
chopping off kids genitals and they want
to chop off 10 year old and 12 year old
genitals and they don't want parents to
know about it and they are very adamant
about it here is the elderly man
pretending to be president
when hospitals libraries and community
centers are threatened and intimidated
excuse me because they support
lgbtq Children and Families we have to
speak out
we must stop the hate and violence like
we just saw in Colorado Springs or a
place of acceptance and celebration
was targeted for violence and Terror
we need to challenge the hundreds of
callus cynical laws introduced in the
states targeting transgender children
terrifying families and criminalizing
doctors who get children the care they
need we have to protect these children
so they know they are loved and we will
stand up for them and say I can seek for
themselves all right first off he just
doesn't know what he's saying he's
babbling all the usual stuff he coughs
into his hand more than anybody is there
literally anyone in America that coughs
in their hand more than Joe Biden right
but he does this okay
the gall to say that the people
literally the people who want to chop
off children's genitals so you get an 11
year old boy and he's like you know I
feel like a girl I like Barbie more than
I like Transformers how is that my 11
year old impression I thought that was
solid
um and then the doctor is like all right
we're going to put you on puberty
blockers and I think we'll you know
we'll start getting the process going to
chop your nuts off that's the doctor
that Joe Biden thinks is good why is it
that we would affirm every little thing
that an 11 year old thinks about
anything and this is a wise is all the
time but this is why I hate this thing
this lgbtq plus it has nothing to do
with me I know plenty of gay people that
are decent people that are parents that
are functioning members of society that
would prefer not to change kids genders
that would prefer not to have a bunch of
whack job drag queens why don't drag
queens do anything else how about a drag
queen go to an actuary event how about
at the national accounting association
annual Gala in Hawaii why don't they
have a bunch of drag queens there why
don't drag queens do a bunch of reading
of history books for high school kids
because they know they'd be freaked out
by it but we can do it and we can abuse
these four-year-old kids they've
conflated these issues so that the very
people who are defending children you
are defending children if you were
trying to make sure that they don't
alter themselves in a way that they
cannot imagine
cannot imagine and we played a video
once or twice before of job of uh Jordan
Peterson talking about the trans issue
and one of the things he says is even if
you were to take the whatever it might
be it's something like
.001 of people who are actually trans
like they are fully trans and they've
dealt with all the psychological
um they've gone to psychologists like
they've really done all the work and
they've really fully fundamentally
believe they are in the wrong body
meanwhile it's exploding by like a
thousand percent across the country so
there's obviously a social conditioning
element to it but even if you just took
that person the person who is truly in
their mind of the wrong body right the
idea that if they take puberty blockers
if they Massacre their body chop off
their breaths chop off their genitals
add genitals all of the stuff that
somehow on the other side they will be
happier
and better off for it that is
we don't know that either and there is a
huge movement of detrans transitioners
right now but let's get away from that
for just a moment and just here's just
general Biden gibberish nonsense
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look you know and a gay man's choir
Washington DC gay man's married
yeah whatever okay that's just usual
nonsense uh here's Nancy Pelosi and she
has to tell the audience when to
Applause because they don't really get
her no this is easy for you because
you're from San Francisco
and that's an Applause line
you're from San Francisco you can get
cracking meth and heroin wherever you
want it here's Cindy Lauper She was a
big star in 1986 and uh she sang at the
event and I'm starting to think that
maybe she should have retired in 1987.
see your true colors
that's why I love
[Music]
[Applause]
the power to all the people
go settle down you nut bag I'd like to
give a special shout out right now I
normally don't do this during the show
but to our our back and YouTube Rumble
guy Chris Chris I know it was discussed
before the show whether we were going to
play that Cyndi Lauper clip because you
love Cyndi Lauper and look Cindy Lauper
1986 when she was doing stuff with
Captain Lou Albano in what was then the
WWF wrestling I liked her too but the
woman has lost her mind she has just
lost her mind like most of these people
do so now let's move over because this
thing is this this weird trans thing
that Joe Biden feels so passionately
about and he so wants to ensure that
doctors can do things to children
without the parent knowing what's going
on uh it's leaking into every part of
society and it's really really nuts here
is a Woman by well I assume she's a
woman she looks like a woman to me but
she might have a penis eye who knows
anymore her name is Jesse pocock
a Woman by the name of Jesse pocock she
is the CEO and executive director of
inside out Youth Services advocacy
organization uh and she was being
questioned on C-Span about whether
parents have rights related to their
children going through these processes
and whether parents should know that
their kids are on hormones Etc once
again we are doing a trans segment here
and the expert her name is Jesse pocock
pocock person is safe and protected we
have uh we are constantly filing reports
of abuse and neglect because of parents
I understand the cases of people who it
sounds like you're deflecting the
question a little bit uh I understand
cases that abuse there's laws to protect
abuse I mean schools actually are
legally obligated to report cases that
abuse same for churches and and the like
anyone who deals with young people but
you you know do parents have a right
should they be informed about what's
going on
do they have a right to know what's
going on in their kids lives
so I think again
those of us who are protecting and
supporting young people are there and
trusted with the information of the
things that they are dealing with in
terms of parents rights to know at
schools I mean here in Colorado parents
don't have the right if a young person
is questioning their gender or their
sexuality there are laws in place that
say that they have the right to process
that with their trusted counselor so you
do and so forth you do a significant
amount of your work with kids even
starting at age 13. yeah what what would
be the age of consent then in your in
your mind
uh in our community the age of consent
to mental health therapy is 12 years old
so the woman who wants to talk to your
children about transitioning and
sexuality and everything else just one
more time her name is Mrs pocock
could have been mocock or less [ __ ] that
would have made more sense
believes that as she said that we have
people who are protecting and supporting
kids
um I could have sworn that was the job
of the parent I don't want pocock
talking to my children pocock will not
come near my children and pocock
shouldn't come near your children do you
think that there's any chance as as the
representative laid out there so she
thinks a 13 year old can walk into her
office and ask about
puberty blockers surgery Etc et cetera
do you think there is any chance that
when that happens so let's let's say
it's a guy did a boy last time so let's
say it's a girl right so a little girl
comes in and she says you know I feel
like a boy I feel I'm 13 years old I
feel like a boy I like baseball I don't
really like dresses whatever do you
think there's any chance in high hell
that pocock and her minions say you know
what actually you're just going through
a phase and by the way there are some
girls that like baseball and sometimes
they turn out to be lesbian sometimes
not they're you know there's a whole
spectrum of things these are the people
who love like the whole spectrum and
diversity and equality of everything and
all that stuff but for some reason with
gender and sex if you feel a little bit
different if you're not freaking you
know nail polish blonde and doing your
thing then you are automatically a dude
it's absolutely crazy and these people
should have nothing to do with anyone
else's children and if you don't realize
what uh what damage this is doing to
people uh here's something from The
Daily Mail and this guy's been making
the rounds ex-navy seal who transitioned
from male to female says he's now
transitioning back blast Virginia or the
VA sorry the blast the VA for giving him
hormones after an hour-long consultation
and call sex change the worst mistake of
my life so there he is on the left there
as a man
there he is as a chick and now there he
is as a man again or chick man whatever
this is out of control this stuff it's
out of control but they're not going to
stop with this and just try to imagine
if they've taken us this far now where
are they going to be at in two years
like that really is the question that
really is the question so what is the
answer you guys know I like answers and
I like Solutions and I like doing stuff
about things instead of just talking
about it so what do you do you elect
people who will fight for you you elect
people who will make sure that they will
get this nonsense out of schools and
they will fight the woke corporations
that are injecting this into all of our
cultural apparatus one of those guys is
Ron DeSantis I happen to talk to him
back in June uh in Orlando home of Walt
Disney and his crazy company uh here's
what Santa said you may remember this
but I think Disney took it one step
further when they put out this
incredible statement after they already
did all their virtue signaling after we
signed the bill saying this was somehow
a violation of Human Rights and that
they would work to see that parents
rights and education were repealed
through the legislature and I'm just
thinking to myself
um you know I took a note to support the
laws and Constitution of the U.S and the
State of Florida I did not take an oath
to subcontract out my leadership to a
corporation based in Burbank California
they don't run this state
okay now that's talk right and what do I
always say I don't just like talk so
what did he do he actually started going
after Disney going after their special
benefits Disney has all sorts of special
benefits tax breaks their own police
force all sorts of crazy stuff that they
got you know 50 60 years ago in Orlando
here in Florida he went after them right
and then all sorts of people kind of got
behind him and people started canceling
Disney plus and stopped watching their
movies and buying their stuff so you
know what happened Disney fired their
CEO Bob chapic we showed you a bunch of
videos with that clown and I said I said
months ago six months ago this guy this
will not end well for him he got eaten
up by the woke diversity machine and
then Disney just in the last month or so
they brought in former Disney CEO so
former and now future Disney CEO Bob
Iger just about a month ago and he's
already reversing course because he's
afraid of backlash both politically and
financially related to his company
here's a virtual question many cast
members had wished that Disney stayed
out of politics Will Disney stay out of
making political statements
you know I think there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political
just not how I view it do I like the
company being embroiled in controversy
of course not it can be distracting and
it can have a negative impact on the
company and to the extent that I can
work to kind of quiet things down I'm
going to do that
okay so it's super interesting there
because he's not like outwardly being
like I'm done with all of this whoa crap
and everything else but he's kind of
saying it now we'll see what Disney does
what was the movie that crashed and
burned with Disney in the last two weeks
Strange World so they had a super woke
movie that came out about two three
weeks ago that completely flopped right
um so hope but obviously that was in the
can way before he took over so hopefully
he will make some adjustments but
DeSantis counter uh contrary to what a
lot of media was reporting he's not
turning around on any of these things
he's not giving him any of those special
benefits back but the point is they are
changing course because we fought back
they next time when the next election
cycle rolls around and Disney and the
execs on the board they're all looking
at the numbers and they're like Well
we'd like to fund a whole bunch of
candidates uh we probably shouldn't go
against this DeSantis guy because he
just won Florida by 20 points and people
have had it with us and our numbers are
dropping on top of the fact that the
economy is kind of sputtering along we
do have some fiduciary responsibility to
the board to the to the shareholders and
we better make note of that so you fight
back people that is what you do have I
been clear about my feelings today
feel clear pretty solid okay uh Tony
Allegra we've got some comments from the
Reuben report.locals.com Community Tony
says dude was a billionaire and couldn't
afford a hair stylist can you pull up
that picture again Connor the picture of
the four of them just standing there
together this yeah look at this clown
this this way his suit bits his body
looks like you could just put your
finger through it the haircut they
thought this was Jesus too
ridiculous speaking of haircuts I have
not been able to get a great haircut
here in Florida you know what happened I
Connor and I've been going to the same
guy and he doesn't speak English
and God bless them I don't need to talk
that my talk for a living so I don't
need to talk when I'm getting my hair
cut and he gave me a couple of decent
ones but then the last haircut that he I
should I should have got to busted out
the picture he literally like zagged me
over here to get you know because
there's a lot of Cubans down here a lot
of Venezuelans they like these like Zing
Zang Zoom things and then he was doing
my beard and he sprayed my beard
I looked like Tony Bettis wait uh not
Tony Bettis what was his name what was
his name the football player Jerome
Bettis Jerome Bettis remember Jerome
Bettis had this very intense beer that's
so anyway uh Phoenix's girlfriend's
moving here and she's a stylist so we're
gonna we're gonna fix this situation
ASAP uh Elizabeth says there's fraud in
campaigns who would have thought big
gasp my shock yeah it's wild and they
they give money to everybody as I said
there's this hedging of the bets right
you you don't always go all in on one
side some people do but you know the the
more clever people they're giving money
to everybody and that and Trump was very
very clear and clean about that uh when
he was running the first time around
about how this whole thing works Hillary
I used to give you money Hillary you
used to call me for money so
yeah it's a corrupt system and you just
got a pill for some truth out of it and
then figure out a way to remain sane and
happy and all that good stuff uh Matt
says Trevor Noah is the anti-matter of
humor yeah I mean on top of everything
else he's deeply unfunny like you could
have completely polar opposite uh
political opinions as me and I could
still recognize that you're funny but he
was just sort of the worst kind of
partisan hack which is what has happened
with Stephen Colbert and the rest of the
late night guys thus leaving uh the
number one show in late night to be Greg
gutfeld's show he's literally I mean
I've said this many times but people
don't realize the other shows if you
look at Colbert you look at uh who else
is on late night even anymore Kimmel or
whatever you look at any of these clowns
they have staffs I kid you not probably
50 to 100 people if not more on those
programs Gutfeld has about five people
there are three camera guys he's got
like two writers and a warm-up guy I go
there's a makeup girl he's got about six
people and he's got the number 1 show in
late night not just by a little bit but
by crazy wide margins which just goes to
show if you do something real and what I
love about Greg and the show it's just
like it's it's loose and it's funny and
it's silly and it's not overly scripted
and rehearsed and all that stuff and and
he lets me do whatever the hell I want
for better orders uh anyway uh if you
want to join us uh for live chat during
the show
reubenreport.locals.com and we did give
you a couple flummox Joe Biden's during
this show but we got one more for you on
the cold clothes and then the uh the
Reuben report holiday party is tonight
there will be there will be much tequila
and uh I'll see you tomorrow everybody
adios and other Partnerships in global
Health security to help save lives and
combat Globe 9 uh covert 19.